now we turn to a town in central
california that literally could dry up
and disappear because it's running out
of water stratfor that's about 40 miles
south of fresno was built on the backs
of farmers as the groundwater has dried
up so is a town turning it into a ghost
of what it once was meteorologist evelyn
taft who was with us last week of our
los languages station kcbs and kcal
shows us what the community is up
against and how residents are trying to
save it here's evelyn
it's 7 a.m in this small central
california town
yeah i made it back so small in fact it
doesn't have a diner instead the locals
get their coffee
here their first drive they got down to
the three yard line every morning a pot
of strong brew greets the regulars
inside this auto parts shop everything's
deteriorated you know over the years
you can't even buy gas here no more you
got to go to lee more it's not just the
gas station that disappeared so did the
old hotel meat market and restaurant in
the farming community of stratford which
some are calling a ghost town what do
you think the future holds
just going to be tough
it's a problem that's been brewing for
years livelihoods drying up all because
of water or lack thereof i had about 20
employees
and then when we downsized
then i had to drop five and acreage wise
it was three thousand acres yes three
thousand then down to two wow this is
where my dad used to live farmer charles
meyer has lived here almost his entire
life but lately his worries have been
growing more than his cotton hopefully
sometime this winter maybe it'll rain
and then if it still doesn't rain then
it'll just stay worked up but it'll stay
fallow
less water from the sky means he has to
get it from underground he recently dug
this well to save his almond and
pistachio orchards the tree looks pretty
bad
from all the yellow leaves
what would happen if you if you lost
these trees and you didn't have the well
well would be a very
tight financial pinch
the bank might try to take the land
so that means no jobs yeah no jobs in a
good water year you'd see water up to
about here jacob westroz with the tulare
lake basin water storage district we're
walking through here we're certainly not
swimming through here correct correct
and we should be swimming his agency's
job is to bring state water from
northern california to 190 thousand
acres of farmland through this canal
this year it's only getting about five
percent of its contractual share from
the state not looking good this year
next year's not looking good either at
all so it could be zero potentially zero
and that means it's not looking good for
the farmers people in stratford yeah no
when the farmers have less water that's
less jobs this is the only pool in town
it was it was yeah we met up with local
teacher robert iscardo at his childhood
home which used to be the unofficial
community pool for local kids it's been
dry for 15 years the water's gone and
when the water is gone the crops are
gone when the crops are gone
we don't have jobs but he refuses to
give up these days he spends his spare
time running a non-profit raising money
to save the town but for him it's about
more than just dollars we had various
grants in the past we had a 5k run but
the big goal is we want this to be a
place that people feel proud to be part
of does it feel empty
at times yes
it does but you know you don't want to
just sit in that emptiness you want to
fill it with hope you think one day
you'll fill it up oh absolutely yeah
that's the plan it's sad that hope
floats here in stratford it might be the
only thing keeping a community alive
if this pool ever gets you know to the
point where we can fill it up again
i think that would be a reflection
on the community being back to what it
was
for cbs mornings i'm evelyn taft in
stratford california
rooting for the town of stratford there
and all those towns struggling with
drought